news voice is the world's first mobile
app that helps you track
where your news is coming from news
voice helps you track what corporate
interests might be influencing the
narratives in the news you read every
day
arm yourself against corporate media
monopolies by downloading the news voice
app
for free using the link right underneath
this video
so yesterday i didn't have a chance to
get to this but i do want to play this
clip for you donald trump has launched
yet another attack on elements of
plumbing
including shower heads and dishwashers
and this has been a really bizarre
obsession for donald trump here he is a
few days ago
talking about i guess how democrats
don't want you to have reasonable water
pressure
uh democrats i guess as far as trump can
trump trump is concerned want very
beta showers whereas trump wants
powerful alpha showers with high water
pressure or something
see if you can understand what trump is
talking about here race is
lower than that we're bringing back
consumer choice and home appliances so
that you can buy washers and dryers
shower heads and faucets so shower heads
you take a shower the water doesn't come
out
you want to wash your hands the water
doesn't come out
so what do you do you just stand there
longer you take a shower longer
because my hair i don't know about you
but has to be perfect
perfect
dishwashers you didn't have any water so
you the
people that do the dishes you press it
and it goes again
and you do it again and again so you
might as well give them the water
because you'll end up using
less water so we made it so dishwashers
now have
a lot more water and in many places in
most places of the country
water is not a problem they don't know
what to do with it it's called rain
they don't have a problem and
old-fashioned incandescent light bulbs i
brought them back
i brought them back
they have two nice qualities they're
cheaper and they're better
they look better they make you look so
much better that's important to all of
us
but they're better and much cheaper
and they were mandated out legislated
out
and we brought them back and they're
selling like hotcakes
so this is like a completely outrageous
rant i mean
these are truly the rantings of a madman
it's meaningless nonsense this is the
type of stuff where
you know you see someone in the subway
uh yelling about this stuff
you probably call crisis services and
say somebody seems to be having a mental
health incident right now and these are
the things that mike pence sits in the
front row and nods along as if this is
normal to hear from a president of the
united states and this is not the only
time that donald trump did something
like this back in december
feels like years ago but it was december
before we at least
knew that coronavirus was in the united
states trump ranted about light bulbs
and remember him saying people are
flushing toilets 10 or 15 times
companies are very happy about that but
together we're
defending the american workers we're
using common sense
we have a situation where we're looking
very strongly at sinks and showers
and other elements of bathrooms where
you turn the faucet on in areas where
there's tremendous amounts of water
where the water
rushes out to sea because you could
never handle it
and you don't get any water you turn on
the faucet you don't get any water
they take a shower and water comes
dripping
out it's dripping out very quietly
dripping out
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times
as opposed to once they end up using
more water
so epa is looking at that very strongly
at my suggestion
you go into a new building or a new
house or new home and they have standard
zone where you don't get water you can't
you can't wash your hands practically
there's so little water comes out of the
faucet
and the end result is you leave the
faucet on and it takes you much longer
to wash your hands
you end up using the same amount of
water so we're looking at
very seriously at opening up the
standard
and there may be some areas where we'll
go the other route
desert areas but for the most part you
have many states where they have so much
water that
it comes down it's called rain that they
don't know
they don't know what to do with it so
it's really weird like what is trump
doing in the bathroom that he's flushing
a toilet 10 or 15 times that's really
strange and
this is about something right and it's
actually about
a few things first is this obsession
trump has not just with toilet flushing
but rolling back
regulations and the idea that the right
has wanted to frame up for a long time
is there's so much regulation
everybody's overburdened by regulations
uh businesses construction companies
consumers it's this burden back-breaking
burden of government regulation
from obama of course there's you know
the water pressure's too low
you can't wash dishes you can't shower
you can't
properly use the toilet apparently
and so they want to frame regulation
happy democrats under the obama biden
administration is passing too many
regulations
and trump is unburdening us
by canceling those regulations now this
is of course
completely crazy like everything's fine
water pressure is fine
dishwashers are working fine
everything's fine here in boston in
massachusetts i should say
we have some of the strictest building
code when it comes to
efficiency and appliances i run my
dishwasher one
time it's a beautiful thing i flush my
toilet one time
it's fantastic i turn on a light bulb
it's a you know cfl
and i get all the light i need i'm able
to read my books i'm able to read my
magazines all of this different stuff
everything's working fine now the and we
have some of the strictest building code
in the country
the sad thing is trump
is actually sort of tiptoeing around
an issue i would love to see a president
make their issue
water quality much of america has
disastrous
water quality in some parts of the
country you can't drink the tap water
in some parts of the country you can but
it's pretty vile
flint michigan obviously the situation
is worse than that
and i would love it if we had a
president who said
water quality is going to be my issue
this is a serious issue you read about
water quality at a global level
you find out that there are so many
deaths just from
lack of water uh that that that is safe
you have you know adults and children
dying from water quality related issues
parasitic infections diarrhea etc
if we had a president listen there's so
many things the president can focus on
that's the truth
if a president said i'm going to do all
of these different things
but one thing that's not getting enough
attention is water quality in the united
states it's an issue of civil rights
it's
an issue of economics it's an issue of
class and
globally my goal is to reduce by
half the number of people that are
getting sick and dying
because of lack of access to just safe
drinking water
that would be such a material
improvement that a determined american
president
as you know the so-called leader of the
free world most of the time
could do and trump is talking about
water but he's talking about
flushing toilets 15 times and i guess
low flow waterheads or something like
that
trump really just making make making
little sense during this event
in general here is trump saying that
there will soon be announcements of
things that nobody thought possible
or had even conceived of
so we have many exciting things that
we'll be announcing over the next uh
eight weeks i would say things that
nobody has even
contemplated thought about thought
possible
and things that we're going to get done
and we have gotten done we've started in
most cases
but it's going to be a very exciting
eight weeks a
eight weeks like i prob i think mike we
can honestly say nobody's
ever going to see eight weeks like we're
gonna have yeah they're going to
announce things that no one has even
contemplated
crystal clear right so something is very
wrong here i don't know whether i would
say
the wheel is spinning but the hamster is
dead i don't know if i would say
because we're talking about lighting and
shower heads the lights are on but
nobody's home
i don't know exactly what the right
phrase is but this is
truly a man disconnected from reality
and
i i keep going back to 36
38 39 of the country
supports this there's a there's there's
people out there
who see this and they say yeah that's
what i'm voting for i'm voting for this
the guy ranting about
light bulbs and flushing toilets
millions tens of millions of people
will be voting for what you just saw in
november for another four years of that
and as i've said before
that's scary the trumpists are as scary
as trump
and the reality is we will we will have
trumpism for longer than donald trump is
in office whether trump leaves
in january or january of 2025 either way
trumpism will outlast trump and that's
going to be a real problem we have to
deal with in this country
for a long time going forward